zone Europe sur sensation
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de zone Europe sur Radio
sensation et sur TV 78 après la Grèce la
Pologne la Suède les Pays-Bas et
l'Allemagne la dernière étape du projet
Guira sur les initiatives vertes en zone
rurale se déroulent en France dans les
Yvelines le projet est soutenu par le
programme
Erasmus plus plusieurs visites sont au
zone Europe
pour baisser notre consommation de gaz
une alternative existe le bois nous
visiterons une chaufferie biomasse
donner une nouvelle vision à un quartier
populaire pour qu'ils deviennent un
éco-quartier nous vous emmènerons dans
le quartier du Bel-Air à Saint-Germain
une ferme proche de la ville vous verrez
que c'est possible depuis des siècles la
ferme de Gally nourrit les habitants à
proximité enfin nous rencontrerons
Ségolène et Christian Hubert producteur
locaux d'huile de colza il nous
partagerons leur expérience
zone Europe sur sensation le fioul le
gaz ont longtemps été la norme pour se
chauffer mais ce sont des énergies non
renouvelables quelles alternatives alors
le bois la chaufferie biomasse des
Merley inaugurée le 7 juillet 2016
approvisionne donc le réseau de
chauffage urbain de la ville de
Saint-Germain en laisse à particularité
donc elle utilise le bois comme énergie
et du bois il n'en manque pas ici
puisque la commune est recouverte aux
trois quarts par la forêt domaniale je
suis avec Stéphane Cravero bonjour
bonjour vous êtes donc responsable de
l'unité opérationnelle de la chaufferie
et vous êtes avec Claude Bastian bonjour
bonjour vous êtes donc référent biomasse
Claude Bastian c'est quoi justement une
chaufferie biomasse comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait la définir alors une chaufferie
biomasse c'est une chaufferie qui brûle
des produits qui peuvent être soit
agricoles des amas de lin de la paille
ou des produits du bois donc des
produits forestiers ce qui est le cas
ici on peut aussi trouver des
chaufferies biomass qui recyclent du
broyat d'élagage du broyat de de
palettes et du des bois d'emballage
Stéphane craveron c'est longtemps
chauffé au fioul et au gaz à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye oui oui on s'est
longtemps chauffé au gaz au fioul et
puis avant c'était le charbon et puis
progressivement la ville depuis des
décennies et rentrer dans une politique
de de verdissement de de son réseau de
chaleur et puis donc du coup on est
passé en 2014 2015 avec cette chaufferie
biomasse qui fait 6 mégawatts et qui qui
permet de faire au-delà de 50% de de
taux NR ce qui est ce qui est ce qui est
assez notable et puis il y a un an et
demi on a complété cette cette énergie
ENR par une une géothermie donc c'est la
ville qui a
qui qui progressivement versit son
réseau de plus en plus donc là
géothermie le bois histoire d'être
complet Claude Bastian le bois on doit
le brûler j'imagine pour pour créer de
la chaleur quand on le brûle ça crée du
CO2 donc en quoi est-ce que c'est plus
vert de chauffer d'utiliser le bois que
le fioul le gaz alors effectivement
lorsqu'on brûle du bois on crée du CO2
mais il faut savoir que ce CO2 passe
dans un cycle de renouvellement et de
captage il faut savoir aussi qu'on ne
coupe pas de forêt pour brûler du bois
ce sont des refus de houpiez ce sont des
connexes de Syrie donc ce qui ne peut
pas être valorisé différemment et
autrement qui est brûlé dans dans ses
chaufferies et donc qui est valorisé
et donc ce bois il est coupé uniquement
dans une zone autour de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye oui tout à fait
nous avons un rayon d'approvisionnement
de 50 km maximum et dont une grande
partie du bois brûlé ici provient de la
commune et de la forêt de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye tout à fait est-ce
que c'est une alternative qui est
particulièrement utilisée en France ou
finalement Saint-Germain-en-Laye est une
exception ah non il y a à peu près
500 chaufferies au bois de toutes
tailles en France de vraiment de toute
taille donc beaucoup de réseaux de
chaleur en France utilisent du bois de
la biomasse comme comme source
principale ou comme à point pour les
apports de chaleur Stéphane Cravero pour
pour finir qui en bénéficie justement de
cette chaufferie on a dit la donc la
ville de Saint-Germain-en-Laye qu'il
l'exploite ce sont les habitants de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye qui directement
sont chauffés via le bois de oui oui
tout à fait donc on peut retrouver tous
types de de d'abonnés donc il y a
principalement des copropriétés donc
c'est surtout de l'habitation il peut y
avoir aussi des collectivités donc on a
des lycées on a des gymnastes on a des
collèges on a des écoles il y a le
centre technique administratif de la
Mairie qui est également raccordé en fin
de compte il y a beaucoup d'abonnés qui
bénéficient de cette chaleur ENR et
merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous et puis on écoute
tout de suite une réaction d'une des
délégations
bonjour je m'appelle Aldona cool et Sky
je viens de Pologne où je travaille à la
Fondation Robert Schuman à
varsoview
c'était vraiment intéressant pour moi
d'être là aujourd'hui et de visiter cet
endroit de voir comment cela fonctionne
comme on sait gérer car parce que j'ai
compris il n'y a pas beaucoup d'endroits
comme celui-ci à Paris ou en France en
général
c'est un projet unique pour moi c'est
également important d'avoir ce genre
d'information car je n'ai jamais rien vu
de tel en Pologne ou dans d'autres pays
oui je pense que vous avez fait beaucoup
de choses bien par ailleurs j'ai appris
que vous ne pratiquiez pas la
déforestation pour les besoins du projet
[Musique]
juste à côté de la chaufferie biomasse
on trouve un centre de valorisation
thermique je suis avec Emmanuel Dosso
bonjour enchanté bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes donc directeur des
travaux chez sort alors ici comment
est-ce qu'on valorise justement
l'énergie alors ici on récupère l'eau
dans un forage qu'on a créé et qui
descend à peu près à entre 600 et 700
mètres que vous voyez juste derrière
vous
et ce forage on a l'eau qui ressort qui
entre à l'intérieur du bâtiment que vous
voyez ici l'eau on y prélève des
calories c'est calories on les injecte
dans une pompe à chaleur c'est
l'équivalent d'un frigo inversé et on
réinjecte ces calories qu'on a récupéré
dans le réseau de chaleur de la ville de
Saint-Germain pour réchauffer le réseau
retour avant qu'il arrive à la
chaufferie biomasse qui est juste
derrière ensuite l'eau dans laquelle on
a prélevé les calories est une eau
potable donc c'est une eau qu'on va
réutiliser et qui va être injecté dans
dans le système d'eau potable de la
ville donc ça repart directement dans
l'usine d'à côté où on va traiter autour
d'une déférisation avant sa
réutilisation concrètement au niveau
énergétique ça permet de gagner combien
de alors au niveau énergétique grosso
modo l'eau elle sort à 27 degrés ici et
quand on y prélève des calories quand
elle ressort elle ressort à 12 degrés
elle repart à 12 degrés vers vers les
rés
et donc on prélève on prélève la
différence d'ailleurs à peu près 15
degrés de calories là dessus et avec le
retraitement des pompes à chaleur on va
réchauffer le réseau retour en général
quand il arrive à son déséquivalences
mais quand il arrive à 70 degrés on peut
le monter jusqu'à
75,80 degrés donc ça permet d'utiliser
moins d'énergie dans la biomasse avec le
avec le bois de la chaufferie pour pour
chauffer le réseau le réseau de chaleur
ce centre de valorisation thermique il
est actif depuis 2021 si je me trompe
pas la démarrer le Noël juste avant le
1er janvier 2021 et on était en service
tout début 2021 donc ça fait à peu près
un an et demi qu'on fonctionne et ça
fonctionne plutôt bien parce qu'on a eu
quelques difficultés au départ à se
mettre en phase sur le pilotage en tout
cas parce que c'est pour piloter les
pompes à chaleur
aujourd'hui on pilote avec la demande de
la biomasse et puis on a trouvé des
modes de fonctionnement et aujourd'hui
ça ça tourne quasiment tout seul merci
beaucoup je rappelle donc vous êtes
directeur des travaux chez sort et on
écoute tout de suite une réaction d'une
des délégations
de l'Afrique
je suis impressionné parce que nous
avons vu aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un
système très intéressant qui permet de
créer de l'eau et de la chaleur pour la
communauté locale
de même que le financement du projet
appartient à la communauté c'est une
façon très intéressante de gérer
l'énergie au niveau local
zone Europe sur sensation pour pouvoir
l'allure au quartier de Bel-Air une
ancienne ZUP zone à urbaniser en
priorité des années 70 la commune de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye avait fait le
choix de lancer donc ce quartier dans un
processus décoquartier aujourd'hui donc
la maison des projets est un lieu qui
accompagne ce cette démarche et les
différents projets Paul Joly bonjour
vous êtes mère adjoint donc de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye en charge
notamment du logement de l'inclusion et
aussi de la ville de demain alors cette
techno-quartier du Bel Air est-ce que
vous pourrez vous pouvez nous parler un
peu de son son historique alors son
historique c'est je dirais toute la
politique de la ville depuis les années
50 comme vous l'avez précisé on est ici
dans un quartier qui fait à peu près 47
hectares il y a environ un peu plus de
5000 habitants et dans dans ce quartier
on a l'originalité d'être la dernière
ZUP d'Île-de-France avec une
construction d'ailleurs d'un architecte
qui s'appelle talibert qui était
l'architecte du parc il devait avoir un
peu trop de béton il est venu le vider
ces derniers camions ici sur le Bel Air
enfin tout ça pour dire que cette zone
aurbanisée en priorité aujourd'hui c'est
aussi des images un peu négatives qu'on
peut voir dans différentes villes de
France le quartier du Bel Air c'est un
quartier populaire avec beaucoup de
logements sociaux et donc une mixité
sociale importante et je dirais que
cette mixité sociale ça peut être vu
comme effectivement quelque chose de
contraignant ou plutôt comme une
opportunité sociétale et c'est un peu le
regard qu'on a posé et donc comment
redorer l'image un petit peu de ce
quartier du Bel Air effacer un peu cette
césarière pensée derrière les zones à
urbaniser en priorité qui sont arrêtés
en 1973 avec le préfet Guichard ça a été
l'idée c'était de lancer une démarche de
labellisation éco-quartier alors c'est
vrai que cette démarche de labellisation
écoquartier elle s'imagine plus sur des
quartiers récents des quartiers neufs
d'ailleurs sur des quartiers
je dirais deux trois quatre cinq
hectares on a on a d'autres
éco-quartiers à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
par exemple Isère Pereire c'est un
éco-quartier ici l'originalité Ali
double elle est d'abord parce qu'on a
posé une démarche éco-quartier sur un
quartier existant sur un quartier
existant où on a rentré dans un
périmètre de 47 hectares ce qui est
énorme et on a pu démontrer ainsi dans
cette démarche d'éco-quartiers que tout
le travail qui est fait par les
différents maires successifs les équipes
municipales successives sur ce quartier
pour plutôt le positiver et c'est ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui et parallèlement
donc c'est une démarche qui a débuté en
2019 aujourd'hui on rentre dans la phase
4 de labellisation dans la labellisation
éco-quartier vous avez quatre labels 1 2
3 4 et là on va rentrer dans le label 4
on a le comité des experts qui vient au
mois de juillet nous audités pour cette
phase 4 la deuxième chose importante sur
cette écoquartier c'est qu'on a mis en
place en 2019 un projet qui s'appelle le
projet action autour de de fondamentaux
qui est de dire si on est bien chez soi
on est bien dans l'espace public pour
être bien chez soi
du développement durable et on fait
beaucoup d'ateliers autour du
développement durable et notamment des
usages en fait ce qu'on veut démontrer
ici sur ce quartier c'est qu'il est
possible de remettre de l'humain dans
l'urbain merci beaucoup Paul jolie
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle donc
que vous êtes mère adjoint de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye on écoute tout de
suite une des réactions des délégations
[Musique]
et je viens d'Allemagne et je suis
éducatrice politique à la Maison de
l'Europe de Bad marine Berg off
Saint-Germain je pense que d'après la
présentation de ce district de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye appelé Bel-Air et
la façon dont il fonctionne on peut dire
que c'est un modèle durable
c'est ce dont nous avons besoin à l'aire
du réchauffement climatique et de la
crise globale planétaire vivre en ville
devient de plus en plus difficile mais
quand j'écoute des idées à propos du
verdissement général d'un quartier en
impliquant les habitants eux-mêmes on
les invitant à être plus participatif
cela réchauffe mon cœur
j'espère réellement qu'avec des idées
telles que celle-ci nous pourrons
affronter les difficultés et nous
pourrons définitivement affronter
l'avenir
[Musique]
depuis 10 siècles la ferme de Gally est
posée ici entre la forêt de Marly et les
collines de Saint-Cyr l'école cultiver
d'abord par des moines puis par des
laboureurs et des maraîchers des terres
dont la mission a toujours été de
nourrir les populations aux alentours du
mieux possible la ferme de Gally est
devenue ensuite les fermes de Gally pour
devenir une marque qui totalise
aujourd'hui un chiffre d'affaires de 55
millions d'euros et qui défend une autre
vision de l'agriculture je suis avec
Bruno Gansel bonjour bonjour à vous vous
êtes responsable de la communication des
fermes de Gally cette ferme c'est ferme
ont aujourd'hui beaucoup évolué par
rapport aux dernières années est-ce que
vous pouvez nous parler des derniers
évolutions de cette ferme de Gally donc
les femmes de Galy évoluent
effectivement un petit peu tous les
jours on est sur nos fondamentaux qui
sont des des activités de production
production agricole on est toujours
agriculteurs producteurs de grandes
cultures bléors j'ai plus de culture
spécialisée à la cueillette
où on a une soixantaine d'hectares de
fruits de fleurs et de légumes et à côté
de ces activités de production on a
d'autres activités d'accueil du public
dans nos différentes fermes pédagogiques
on en a trois autour de Paris donc celle
où on se trouve ici à Saint-Cyr-l'École
une à Sartrouville et puis une ouverture
récemment à Saint-Denis dans le à
Saint-Denis et puis on a bien évidemment
d'autres activités de commerce à travers
les différents magasins le magasin de la
ferme à Saint-Cyr-l'École ici juste à
côté et puis le magasin qui se trouve à
Feucherolles et dans ces magasins on a
des points de restauration qui sont des
cafés qu'on retrouve aussi bien à
Feucherolles et à Saint-Cyr-l'École et
on vient d'ouvrir ça c'est la dernière
nouveauté pour répondre précisément
votre question à Saint-Cyr-l'École une
crêperie qui a ouverte huit jours alors
différents produits proviennent de la
ferme il y a des fruits des légumes des
animaux aussi racontez-nous il y a plein
de il y a plein de produits alors à la
cueillette on retrouve uniquement des
des produits que l'on produit dans nos
champs puisque le principe nous on
cultive et puis le grand public vient et
cueille quand c'est à maturité donc ils
viennent cueillir dans nos champs on
peut pas faire plus direct que ça en
terme de consommation et au magasin il y
a un certain nombre de produits qui
viennent de nos productions à nous je
pense au miel qui viennent nos ruches à
l'huile de colza ou l'huile de cameline
qui vient des champs qu'on cultivent
dans le parc de Versailles qui se trouve
juste derrière nous on a plein de
légumes secs des lentilles du quinoa du
pois chiches du jus de pomme qui est un
des produits emblématiques de la maison
et puis également les pommes et les
poires que l'on cultivons dans une autre
ferme qui se situe dans le Val-d'Oise à
quelques à quelques kilomètres d'ici et
puis dans le magasin en termes de
produits alimentaires on a beaucoup de
produits qui viennent directement de
chez des collègues agriculteurs ou des
petites transformations
transformateurs on travaille beaucoup en
circuit court qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
circuit court un circuit court c'est pas
plus d'un intermédiaire entre le
producteur et le consommateur et bien
souvent au niveau du magasin si ce sont
pas nos produits nous sommes ce fameux
intermédiaire ce qui nous permet de
travailler en circuit court on est
encore une fois agriculteur on a une
grosse appétence une grosse attirance
une grosse passion pour ce métier et le
fait de travailler en circuit court
permet de savoir d'où viennent les
produits de connaître les producteurs et
d'être sûr de ce que l'on vend alors
vous avez accueilli les différentes
délégations venues de toute l'Europe du
projet Guira
qu'est-ce que vous leur avez montré en
terme d'initiative verte que l'on fait
ici dans les Yvelines j'ai essayé de
leur expliquer un petit peu l'histoire
de l'histoire de la maison ici
l'histoire des fermes de Gally on leur
montrant comment est-ce que
les fermes de Gally est une entreprise
innovante avec des fondations fortes un
métier d'agriculture donc lié alors
agriculture en zone périurbaine à
proximité immédiate de de la ville
puisque quand ça roule bien on met un
quart d'heure 20 minutes pour être à
Paris et comment est-ce que au fil du
temps c'est un processus qui a été long
comment est-ce que l'entreprise a évolué
pour adapter ses produits et ses
services
temps pour proposer des produits
alimentaires ou des produits végétaux en
circuits courts
aux clients aux consommateurs et puis
comment est-ce qu'on a apporté de
nouveaux produits de nouveaux services
pour les accueillir chez nous pour vivre
une vraie expérience de une vraie
expérience de nature à travers
l'expérience qui vont pouvoir vivre en
venant récolter aujourd'hui les fraises
les courgettes et autres produits ou en
venant à la ferme ouverte et les enfants
vont pouvoir faire eux-mêmes leurs pains
etc du miel de faire un atelier de
jardinage faire du beurre et donc j'ai
essayé d'expliquer à ces délégations
comment est-ce que au travers des 50
dernières années et c'est un travail
quotidien et qui perdure encore
aujourd'hui comment est-ce que au
Conseil 50 dernières années les fermes
de Gally
développé des activités des produits et
des services autour de leur métier de
base qui est le métier d'agriculteur et
producteur et bien merci beaucoup Bruno
je rappelle donc que vous êtes le
responsable de la communication des
fermes de Gally et puis on écoute tout
de suite ce qu'on a pensé une des
délégations
et je viens d'une île grecque Rhodes
la visite à la ferme était géniale riche
en informations ça doit être réellement
une expérience incroyable pour les
enfants afin qu'ils comprennent d'où
vient la nourriture sur la table et
comment respecter la nature en donnant
en prenant en interagissant avec les
animaux d'une façon vraiment durable
interactive
[Musique]
tout ce qui est sur la table il parvient
grâce à un processus ce n'est pas juste
acheter des choses au supermarché tout
est un organisme vivant
c'est ce que nous devons faire en tant
qu'humain c'est la meilleure façon
d'avoir une réelle interaction avec la
nature
interaction
[Musique]
autre exemple de circuit court à présent
l'huile la plaine de Versailles une
exploitation agricole dirigée par
Christian Hubert producteur et
transformateur de colza son modèle
d'exploitation visa préserver la terre
avec une agriculture de conservation des
sols une agriculture de une vision et
une agriculture certifiée à haute valeur
en environnementale on en parle tout de
suite Christian uber bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous dans une Europe
alors quels sont les quatre principales
valeurs de l'exploitation
[Musique]
juste pris pour que les exploitants
puissent vivre avec du fruit de leur
travail
quatrième point on produit tous selon
des méthodes vertueuses pour
l'environnement alors c'est ma
définition mais ça comprend plusieurs
labels connus ou moins connus qui ont
tous un côté positif pour le moment donc
avec toi biologique j'en viens pas tout
le monde connaît mais avant d'être bio
il y a trois années finalement de
conversion donc ces trois années
compliquées pour les producteurs donc on
accompagne finalement ces producteurs de
conversion véritable biologique après un
autre système dans lequel on croit
beaucoup c'est tout ce qui est de
conservation des sols
donc c'est merveilleux pour
l'environnement c'est merveilleux pour
l'érosion
pour le CO2 bref ça a beaucoup d'autres
vertus en complément d'actobiologique et
enfin l'agriculture de précision aussi
et il y a également l'acteur de
précision voilà qui est l'utilisation va
dire des moyens technologiques
d'aujourd'hui pour écouter la plante le
seul et pour éviter finalement de de
polluer et après tout ce qui est
certifié via le HVE au-delà
environnemental ou l'ISO 14001 qui était
un management de l'environnement par
progrès continue alors l'ensemble de vos
produits vous les vendez principalement
en circuit court ou ailleurs aussi en
France
alors tout est vendu à proximité donc
c'est essentiellement Yvelines huile de
France donc il y a quelques sachets qui
s'échappent de l'Île-de-France mais
l'objectif c'est vraiment de rester
local
après donc on fait circuit court donc
directement consommateur ou en passe
également pas des grossistes qui sont
indispensables joint notamment on
alimente les collèges des épines il y a
110 collèges les Yvelines et donc on
nous producteur n'a pas la capacité de
livrer le même jour sans du collège en
même temps donc on passe par des
grossistes merci beaucoup Christian
Hubert d'avoir été avec nous j'aurais
besoin que vous êtes producteur à
l'huile de la plaine de Versailles et on
écoute tout de suite une réaction d'une
des délégations
tout d'abord mon nom est Sofia malme et
je viens de Suède
je pense que nous avons fait ici notre
meilleur visite car elle apporte de
l'espoir grâce au fermier qui travaille
ensemble et qui ont modifié leur culture
à cause du changement climatique qui
cultive plus pour les hommes et moins de
nourriture pour les animaux
zone Europe s'est terminée pour en
savoir plus sur le projet Guira ça se
passe sur les réseaux sociaux de la
Maison de l'Europe des Yvelines et vous
pouvez revoir toutes les émissions sur
le projet sur la chaîne Youtube de radio
sensation très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]